Oh what is going on YouTube now going up
everyone had three and you see when our
sugar I always wanted to be a Doug
that's me donut gang psyche a gangster a
pit Walker a blood bag or a box of chalk
oh he's also wrong I'm not gonna lie was
obviously the worst gangster on earth
because ain't nobody wanted me to be in
the gang
I kept on wearing the wrong colors and
[ __ ] hey you bet Crips Oh day [ __ ] god
dick David you wearing the wrong colors
quick what wait what hot work
oh we're not ready did you set on the
mass emails I didn't get one lord knows
what some y'all would aspire to be a
gangster but I'm here to tell y'all
something y'all just don't got it so
y'all we know what it is LCI baby let's
get it let's Oh too much too much bring
down stop trying to be something that
you're not out of all the things you
wanted to be growing up you woke up one
day and said mama imma be a dumbass
here's the thing people it is a lot
easier finding yourself then finding
something else to be you are not a thug
Mikal your daddy's a pastor and your mom
is a third grade teacher anybody live
okay wake up [ __ ] get out here before
dark like pray for you or something
every single wannabe does the first
thing they want to do is make up a
gangster name that is the dumbest [ __ ]
I've ever heard that one when you're a
kid and you wanted to play Power Rangers
and you were the Red Ranger and you
thought they gave you superpowers some
[ __ ] don't call me Thompson doll
from now on I'm dagger face Oh row your
dagger face now why are you why are you
called aggravation [ __ ] cuz I will go
I'm not called a dick I was like I don't
know I was really drunk well let me ask
you something why would you actively
choose to be a thug I'm talking about
you kids that never grew up in the
ghetto your whole life or even you about
one and then one day you decided hey I'm
gonna be an idiot
and listen I only say this because I had
made those same mistakes myself you know
how I feel all of the Gator I had to go
to a library and look up how to gangbang
and see what every ten seconds by
throwing up gang time any idea how many
games I got together they don't want me
in them I could never get the signs
right and [ __ ]
Westside [ __ ] this way dog is 2w
Westside uh-huh what was that no I knew
that man I was like you know all this if
you want some Eminem you know I've heard
people say some of the dumbest reasons
for being in the game each I need to be
a began just in case I need to protect
my fale protect yourself
[ __ ] what's gonna heaven you live
in the summer not a mom no [ __ ] I live
in the concrete jungle [ __ ] the closest
thing you have in the country is when
your mama dropped you on your big-ass
head your dumb [ __ ] my friends there are
certain people that grew up with a
certain life stuff that I understand
that it is hard to get out not every
single one of us is fortunate enough not
to have to hustle when they're young kid
grow up in a great neighborhood and not
have family problems but that's just the
reality of things I know some news
they've been banging since they were
little kids because their family did it
and their family before did it and so
that's what they grew up with but for
those of you out there they have no
reason to wait you are not a thug and
you know how you gonna find out you're
not a thug when you're prison and you
got a big-ass dildo next to your face
now think about this [ __ ] Ping's
all around if later on tonight I asked
you to be my girlfriend
right no what I want is that police
siren would you shut the [ __ ] up I'm
trying to pop being a thug and you're
not helping actually you are